Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel podcast where we discuss
all things feeder series.
On today's episode, we're going to be doing a recap of basically all the feeder series
races that have happened in the past two weeks.
Your hosts today are myself, Robin, Evan, Nova, and Thia.
Okay, so I guess F2 is up first.
This weekend as part of the whole, you know, Bahrain, Saudi cancellation, we were at Canada
this past week.
Definitely interesting.
Our qualifying had Van Hoepen on pole, I don't know what he was doing, how that happened.
That Trident is, I don't know, but...
Van Hoepen on pole in a Trident is crazy.
Literally.
Yeah, and then alongside that we had Camara second, Dunne third, Tsolov fourth, Stenshorne fifth,
I'm not going to bother going through the whole top ten, it's probably pointless anyway
to go through the whole top ten, but I guess it's almost most of the same usual suspects.
It's important to mention that both Camara and Dunne got penalties.
What was it for? Impeding, I think?
So they both got penalties so they didn't start second and third.
Sprint race, because qualifying- sprint race.
Leon win, Mini second, Stenshorne third, Van Hoepen, Fittipaldi, Beganovic, Camara, Bilinski.
Camara, still, he's just not that good, quite frankly.
I think there were things that happened in the race and I did not write them down clearly,
but he's just not that good.
We had some contact with John Bennett, out of all people, from Stenshorne and Tsolov.
Every single time F2 is mentioned, we milk into the whole Mechachrome bad, car bad, blah
blah blah.
This time it was genuinely like Bennett just got hit and his engine just died.
I think, quite frankly, if we had a starter in the cars, he could have just kept racing.
Of course, Mechachrome decides we don't need to have any starter or any battery or anything
inside the car, so anti-stall is terrible in F2, as anyone who watches knows.
I guess nothing to say other than, you know, unfortunate, but Mechachrome got to sort out
something.
But they weren't, because F2 keeps paying them the big bucks.
And it's also important to note that Alex Dunne had gotten a penalty, again.
Alex Dunne gets a penalty, fork found in kitchen.
He just misses Victor Marlins a little bit.
Yeah.
I feel like he'd be, if he would stop colliding with people, he would be, he'd actually be
better.
Can we talk about Fittipaldi, that being P5?
Yeah, that's a concept and a half.
I honestly, quite frankly, I did not pay attention to him at all.
And when I was writing the notes, I was like, hang on, Fittipaldi P5, okay.
That's certainly something, I suppose.
I don't know how he got the AIX there, considering what happened in the feature race, which we'll
get to later with him.
But yeah.
So I mean, I have no, I have nothing really to say other than just, I don't know how
he got there.
It's probably, I'm trying to remember, someone got penalties, right, in the sprint race?
Other than just like-
I think there were quite a few penalties, I don't actually remember.
But onto the feature race, it was a wet feature race.
And F2 and wet weather is not a very good combination.
We had ‘Van Hoepen had hit the Wall of Champions’ at one point.
We had drivers pitting for slicks, including Fittipaldi.
And it was really funny just watching him come out of the pits, and instead of continuing
on the track, he just continued to slide out of the pits and hit the wall.
Watching that replay actually made me laugh, I actually could not-, I was like-
It was the most anti-climactic crash I've ever seen.
Literally.
I did note in here, because while I was watching the race, I did note in here, Bilinski pretty
good.
No, it did not happen actually, I lied.
Quite clearly lied.
To be fair, this happened when this was like, everyone, when the safety car came out for
Van Hoepen and everyone pitted for slicks, and he stayed out of the alternative strategy.
And then nevermind, he went wide in like lap 19, and then he just decided to die afterwards.
So don't know why I noted him down, but he's there in the notes, I suppose.
If Tsolov got hit by Maini, Tsolov would have probably been up here honestly in the top
10, but got hit behind, and he did recover decently enough, but I think he got a penalty.
Wouldn't he have been on the podium probably?
Uh, yeah, I think so.
Probably would have been on the podium.
Why is Maini still here?
Yeah.
I don't understand how he's here, or how Alpine justifies to keep him in the academy,
or there's anything about him in general.
There's this very beautiful thing called Money.
I love motorsports, guys.
I love motorsports.
I love everything about it.
I love how much money there's in here.
Um, continuation of Camara being Camara, which is to say, not good.
Terrible.
His wheel-to-wheel is, oh my god.
I've never understood, I think we've discussed this before, but I don't understand how people
rate him that well, because he really isn't that good.
He's a decent driver.
He is good to an extent, but he's not amazing.
I don't know, I don't have the words to describe what he is, but he's not the next Max Verstappen,
you know?
Yeah.
Agreed.
That's what Ferrari wants, but Ferrari, well, does not get what it wants all the time anyway.
So, oh well.
Also mentioning Mechachrome, like I did earlier, we had Beganovic, who got Mechachrome, that
was one of the laps, because for some reason I did not know what lap it was.
Second time getting Mechachromed?
Would have been.
I think he got Mechachromed in Australia, so Australia Mechachromed, and he got Mechachromed,
or was it Canada?
No, it was in Miami.
I think it was Australia.
You can tell I’m bad at it, this ‘knowledge, remembering’ the whole thing.
I don't remember.
It was Australia, because he was on pole, and then he got Mechachromed.
Oh, that's right, okay.
Not a good time for Beganovic and the Mechachrome.
He's really had an unfortunate season.
And also, you might have noticed Alex Dunne, second.
I mean, I guess this is another whole discussion.
Every time we mention F2, it's always a discussion of, oh, Dunne is actually good, like he's
a good driver, he has the speed, but he just doesn't know how to stop hitting into people.
He loves hitting people.
Look, I mean, he just misses Victor Martins that much, I keep using that, but clearly
he does, because seriously.
Can we talk about the radio message?
Can we talk about that?
Okay, for audio listeners, we'll play it here, hopefully, maybe, if F1 doesn't copyright
us.
‘Horney, let's just go at the restart.’
‘Let's work together and build a gap.’
‘We don't want to repeat of the last one.’
Tell who?
But, um, genuinely horny?
Are we serious?
Alex.
Alex, are we good?
Keep in mind that all these drivers know it is broadcasted live on the TV stream.
FOM broadcasted, like, and it must have been funny, FOM decided to broadcast that specific
message as well.
It took me so long to figure out who the hell ‘Horney’ was supposed to be.
Like why?!
He has any other nickname.
He could-
That was the best part of the race.
Could have said just Martinius, could have just said, like, anything.
I'm pretty sure Alex has called Martinius Marty or something like that at some point.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
They have normal nicknames for each other, but no, he has to call him ‘Horney’!
Cause of course he does.
It was really funny, though, to be fair.
So I guess thank you for adding some joy and fun and whimsy into the race, Alex Dunne.
But also, come on, man.
Herta did pretty well this weekend, which was really nice to see.
Finally starting to move up a bit, you know.
I don't think he should be here.
Still, go back to IndyCar, please.
F2 is not a real series.
Go back to IndyCar, Colton.
If only the FIA would have done this thing of awarding ‘IndyCar: professional racing series’
more points than F2, but alas, that is not happening.
I think they changed the Super License points as soon as he left.
So really, he’s just cursed, quite frankly, then.
That's really unfortunate, actually.
Insanely unfortunate for him.
I'm still mad he's in F2.
Still mad about that.
Moving on, we have F1 Academy also held in Canada.
I think before we talk about anything else, we need to give a really big shout out to
Alisha Palmowski for winning two races with a margin of over 10 seconds.
She broke the record in her first race, and then she decided to break her own record in the second one.
And that's just, that's insane.
That was amazing to watch as well, just seeing her pull away from the rest of the grid.
They would do the overhead shot and you wouldn't even see her within frame.
It was actually genuinely crazy to watch.
It was amazing.
Then when she went, ‘oh my god, guys, I think my engine's dying’ at the very last lap of the race.
That scared me.
And I'm not even a die-hard Alisha fan, so I can only imagine how Alex felt, for example.
But yeah, Alisha is insane.
She's a league above everyone else, I think.
In terms of other drivers, Mathilda Paatz got her maiden podium and then followed it up with her first win,
which is always very nice to see.
Always very nice.
And this is a bit further into the future, but the Central European Zone F4 just happened this weekend,
and she was pretty good in that as well, consistently scoring points and all that in a field of how many drivers?
Like 40, 50?
There's a lot of drivers in F4CEZ for whatever reason, but she's been pretty decent in that as well,
which, again, is always nice to see.
And I hope that Aston Martin keeps her after F1 Academy and just keeps her as part of their academy properly.
Yeah, she shows really good promise, actually, as a driver.
I kind of feel bad for Ferreira, because she won a race on the road, but then she got a penalty for a jump start.
And I saw the jump start on the start of the race, but no one else was discussing it at all.
So I was like, am I just imagining things? Is that not a jump start?
But then they replayed it several times, replayed it from Alba's on-board.
I think it was Alba's on-board anyways.
And it was a really blatant jump start.
And I feel bad, because her race engineer on the radio told her,
oh yeah, no, it's not a jump start, you know, keep doing what you're doing.
And then it ended up being a jump start anyways.
Speaking of Alba, this weekend, once again, not the greatest showing from her.
I don't know what to say. I mean, I expected more from her. I feel like everyone expected more from her.
Because I said this in the episode where we were talking about Shanghai, but she should be better than this.
She should not be making rookie mistakes.
She needs to lock in, basically.
Can we put up that graphic of Dino saying you just need to lock in?
She needs to lock in if she wants to do anything after F1 Academy.
I don't see her doing a Formula Regional Series next year.
Like some of the other girls who are in their second season, I can see them going to GB3, EC3, maybe FREC.
But I can't see Alba doing that.
And I got reminded of the rule change where F1 Academy will allow certain drivers to do a third year if they need to.
And unfortunately, I feel like Alba might just end up doing a third season of F1 Academy.
Which is really, really sad.
Because again, I don't see her moving up to Formula Regional at all.
Yeah, and I doubt she keeps wanting to do the whole few off races in BF4.
She is subjected to a lifetime of British F4 with Chris Dittman Racing.
No!
Ella Lloyd was kind of nowhere the entire weekend.
And I feel like this is just having Alisha run off with the title.
I probably shouldn't have said that, now she's gonna be cursed.
We can't say anything on this podcast, you've cursed her for the rest of the season. Good job.
We'll get into the whole cursing thing when we get to British F4.
I will shut up about Alisha now, because we're not allowed to say anything positive about anyone on this podcast.
But Alba has kind of been nowhere, unfortunately.
Was she having issues during qualifying?
I didn't actually watch qualifying.
It seemed to be that, and so that kind of put her within the midfield, which just didn't set her up for a very good race.
And being in the midfield in any feeder series race is not fun.
Payton had a pretty good weekend.
She got a podium, was it one podium, two podiums? I don't remember.
Did she inherit a podium after Alba got penalized?
Yes, yes she did.
Because somebody was talking about it and they were like, oh this podium now has an average age of 15-16.
And it was the youngest average age of an F1 Academy podium.
I think it's 17, there's no 15 year olds in an F1 Academy.
Why did I say 15?
Yeah, I think that was the youngest podium ever.
I don't remember who was on it, but Payton was on it.
And she's like, what, 2009?
Which is kind of scary. I don't like that.
Oh yeah, because Countryman was also on it, and Countryman I think is 2010.
Kaylee Countryman, by the way, podium.
I'm very glad about that.
Kaylee, I really like Kaylee.
And I think her doing F1 Academy as a double campaign with USF 2000.
I think she's doing USF 2000.
I get really confused with the Road to Indy stuff, but she's doing one of the Road to Indy series.
And she's been doing pretty well there as well.
I think she got her first top 10 there in one of the recent weekends.
And so I think having F1 Academy to help her develop outside of America and then doing her main campaign...
Is USF technically her main campaign? I don't know.
Really, F1 Academy is considered her main campaign, but whatever.
Either way, she's doing well in both series. That's my point.
Natalia had a bit of bad luck this weekend.
Who was she taken out by? Was it Robertson?
Yes, I think so.
I don't remember, but she was spun around by someone in one of the races.
This is the problem with having three races in one weekend. I don't remember what happened in which race.
And the thing with F1A, all the accidents happened at the same turn and corner, so they all blur.
Yeah, there was one point where I think it was in the reverse grid race.
It was in the reverse grid race because Alisha won the other two.
But where Megan Bruce and Alisha Palmowski ended up in the wall, I think they both ended up continuing afterwards.
But that was the thing that happened.
So moving on to the next series.
And I still can't believe these past two weekends were real, but we're moving on to FREC.
So, first of all, Zandvoort.
Zandvoort happened!
Zandvoort, I was really impressed by Seb Wheldon.
I feel like over the past couple weekends, some of the main title contenders, or some of the people who I thought would be main title contenders, have kind of been a bit washed, I'm afraid.
But I've been really impressed by Seb.
He took both wins, and both of those wins were in the same weekend.
Zandvoort was a two-race weekend, unlike Austria, which was three races, and Spa, which was also three races.
Zandvoort was only two.
We had a couple incidents.
Was it Kostic, who ended up upside down at some point?
Kostic barrel-rolled, yes.
Same race that all the Tridents were taken out, actually.
Trident were not having a good race.
I don't remember what happened to them, but it was not great.
R-ace, Olivieri had a much better weekend than the first weekend.
He got a podium, and he didn't get the podium taken away from him, unlike a certain other RACE driver in another series(cough, cough, Andy Consani)
I'll get into that later.
But we kept the podium, and we gained some pretty good points in the championship.
And like we said in the first weekend, KNB-I’m sorry, Nova-KNB cannot drive in the midfield.
Poor Yuki, he just took Yuki out.
I mean, Yuki continued the race anyways, but why?
It was very similar to what he did to Powell, actually.
It was in FRMET Round 1, Race 2, where they were coming around the corner, and instead of going around the corner, he just went straight.
And I have no idea why he did that.
And then he gets...
Why does he keep doing this?
And then he gets a 10 second penalty, which puts him in 23rd.
And the...
He's on 6 penalty points now, by the way.
I feel like it's a competition between him and Alex Dunne to see which good driver can get a race ban first.
Yeah, oh god, and he's actually really good as well, which is the problem.
He's fast, but he just can't race in the midfield.
That's his problem.
I don't know what's wrong with him.
He needs to basically get out of the midfield as soon as possible in order to have a redeeming race, basically.
Also, from the Prema side, that appealed penalty that still hasn't been decided upon?
We need to elaborate on that a little bit.
Prema, what was it that they did?
They had fans on the car or something?
Yeah, so they basically put on fans onto Tomas Stolcermaniss and Kean Nakamura-Berta's cars.
And that apparently was an infringement.
So they were supposed to be disqualified from qualifying.
What was it?
The result of the infringement was that they were meant to be disqualified from qualifying and they were both supposed to start from the back.
And also Alex Munoz ended up with some sort of infringement that had him disqualified from qualifying, so he also started from the back.
So I thought it was like, ‘oh cute, they have some company in the back.’
But then Prema appealed that and the appeal had the disqualification suspended, basically.
And until now, we don't know the result of the appeal.
But I heard from some journalists that during that weekend, obviously, it's been a good week and a half-ish since then.
Yes, basically.
At the time, journalists were saying that if the appeal was rejected, both cars would be disqualified from the race completely.
So I thought that was kind of useless.
And they should have just had them start from the back anyways, because what happens if the appeal gets rejected and then you just lose whatever points you got?
It would have been easier to not climb up from the back but have those points guaranteed for you.
But whatever, not my team, not my circus, not my monkeys.
Unfortunately, it is my circus and my monkeys, so I will have to keep an eye out on that.
I was hoping they would do something about it before the weekend ended.
I'm assuming that since that weekend is over and the next weekend is also over, that nothing's going to come out of that.
But who knows, maybe at the end of the season, suddenly we'll get Kean Nakamura-Berta and Tomass Stolcermanis disqualified from a race that happened months ago because their appeal failed.
That reminds me of the whole fiasco of 2024 F4 where the winner of the championship was decided months after the race had happened.
That was French F4, yeah?
That was French F4, yeah.
But yeah, Al-Dhaheri was kind of nowhere, which was a bit disappointing considering where he was in the first round.
But Ninovic was nowhere as well, I don't know what happened to Rodin, but completely gone.
But Al-Dhaheri did kind of redeem himself in Spa, which was just this weekend.
We had a double header from FREC and I still don't believe that Spa was real.
Let's start from the very beginning before we go into any of the events.
Race 1 was normal-ish.
Alex Munoz ended up on pole and he won the race from pole.
But before we even get into the race, race 1 was originally meant to happen during some really heavy rain.
And they started the race under safety car and they had a couple formation laps and then they realized the rain was way too heavy to continue.
And during the pre-race interviews, they interviewed Sebastian Wheldon and he literally said,
‘I don't understand why we're even doing this race’ because the rain was that heavy.
And I'm really glad that eventually they cancelled the race.
And I'm also really glad that instead of cancelling the race that was decided by proper quali, they cancelled the reverse grid race.
So Alex Munoz still ended up with a chance to start the race on pole.
Which, good decisions from the race directors.
Yeah, and he still got to keep his pole points as well.
Speaking of race direction, that was the worst race direction I've ever seen in my life.
What was happening?
The drone quality was bad.
The commentator kept mixing up the drivers' names.
He referred to Ninovic by Abhkazava or one of the other ones around.
And I was like, wait a minute, no, that's the wrong one.
He said, the Trident of Olivieri.
Yes, he did, because I think he was trying to refer to...
Someone needed to give him a coffee or something because what was going on?
Ah yes, the Trident of Olivieri.
I took a pause when he said that and I went, don't think that's the right car or the driver.
Ended up being the Trident of Popov, by the way.
But Olivieri was behind him, I think.
But anyways, Alex Munoz won the race from pole.
R-aceended up 2nd, 4th, and 6th.
Which was amazing, and I'm so happy.
Olivieri was the last R-ace, but who cares, we were 2-4-6.
All three of the drivers in points. Woo!
After the horrors of the first two weekends, I am very happy.
Speaking of our race and Olivieri,
after the first two races, or well, after the only two races,
Olivieri closed down the gap.
The gap between him and Francot, who were P4 and P5.
He was P5 and Francot was P4.
He had half of Francot's points.
Franco was on 70 and he was on 36.
Which is diabolical.
That was after race 1.
He closed down the gap a little bit after race 2,
because CL Motorsport was absolutely nowhere the entire weekend.
Yeah.
Franco, did he even score any points?
I don't think he scored points.
I don't think so, because I think he was just towards the midfield or the back at the very worst.
There was basically no hurrah about him at all this entire weekend.
And I was like, the CL is gone.
Where have they gone?
Yeah, I don't know.
There was something wrong with CL this weekend.
Or maybe they're just going back to their usual and the first two weekends were just a fluke.
Maybe.
Gosh, race 2 as well.
Quali was weird.
The quali for race 2 was so funny, because what was it?
Abkhazava caused a yellow flag during quali 2.
And it meant that KNB couldn't finish his lap.
And I think neither could Wheldon.
So they both started, I think Wheldon started 10th and KNB 12th, was it?
No, because Costa was 10th.
Wheldon was lower than usual, but I think he was still up in...
He was like P7, P8 maybe.
He finished the race somewhere low down in the top 10.
I don't remember where exactly he finished.
Was it like 9th or 10th, something like that?
Lowkey washed.
He just fell to the top 10.
He just fell to 10th.
No one knew why.
They didn't even mention it.
The fights in the middle of the top 10 were really scary.
Because I'm 18 years old and I'm scared of Kean Nakamura-Berta.
And he's probably only an inch taller than both of us.
I was really scared, but Kean actually managed to get through the midfield without causing a collision.
Without contact?
I'm so proud of him.
I was so scared when he was racing Olivieri.
Olivieri did end up touching Ninovic at some point, but nothing came out of that.
At least I don't think anything came out of that.
No, nothing was said about it.
The safety car restart incident between Gowda and Hanna was ridiculous.
It was so...and Hanna went off scot-free as well.
I was waiting for the race to restart because I was hoping that Olivier would gain a few more positions or KNB would get desperate and something would happen.
But no, the safety car ended and then suddenly Hanna is in the back of Gowda.
Obviously they had to call the safety car again.
It was directly in the camera shot.
We didn't need to get a replay or anything.
It was just directly there and it was so funny.
Poor Dion.
He finished the weekend with two DNFs.
Because in race 1 he just crashed in a corner that had no cameras in it.
So we just didn't know what happened.
We just knew he was out.
He dropped to the back and my heart stopped.
I was like, oh no, Dion.
I still can't believe that Popov won a race.
Like I was happy for Munoz when he won race 1.
But what is Popov doing?
Oh man, who knows anymore.
Przyrowski was fourth.
The podium was Popov, Abhkazava, and Al-Dhaheri.
Man.
What a world we live in.
And as if FREC wasn't bad enough, Italian F4 was also a thing that happened.
Oh god, the stupid decisions.
Can I have a second to crash out over Italian F4?
Because first of all, I need to apologize for what I said about R-ace GP in the last episode where we were recapping Misano.
Because I said that that weekend was the biggest stinker I've ever seen from R-ace.
But I was wrong.
I was proven wrong the weekend right after.
This possibly was the worst stinker I've ever seen.
And I swear to god, if I get proven wrong in the next Italian F4 weekend again, I'm going to start sobbing my eyes out.
Actually, I'm not even going to be on the podcast episode for it.
I'm just going to be busy crying.
Because race 1 ended with an R-ace 19-20-21-22.
And it was really funny watching them all cross the line together and, you know, do the lap afterwards, just all together.
It's like that one Twitter meme of, ‘oh my god, they really are a family.’
But it was horrible.
And man, like, I have no words.
And race 2, I'm going to focus on one specific driver right now.
Andy (Consani) finished race 1 in P21.
He started race 2, he had a 3-place grid drop or a 2-place grid drop for something, I don't remember what it was.
I think it was causing a collision.
And then he ended up starting race 2 in P5.
He finished race 2 in P2.
However, he got a 25-second penalty.
What?
In what world do you get a 25-second penalty for a collision?
And I watched the race back, so I can try and figure out what collision he got the penalty for.
He got the penalty for tapping Maccagnani.
And, okay, I guess he probably caused damage to Maccagnani’s car.
And that was what had Maccagnani DNF.
But I don't think that warrants 25 seconds.
But the 25-second penalty dropped him down to P21.
So, with a double P21 and another race to still go, I was very worried that Andy would not qualify for race 4.
Because I've explained the quali format in other episodes before, but two P21s are not good for you.
And the other R races ended up qualifying for race 4.
Andy did not.
And with Maccagnani DNFing twice, and Costoya also DNFing twice, the ‘did not qualify’ list ended up having all three of them.
And they should be three of the best drivers on the grid.
And all three of them did not even qualify for race 4.
Do you understand why I'm saying this weekend was not real?
Also, this section is going to be kind of just me, unless Thia wants to say anything.
I was, and then I forgot what I was going to say, so never mind.
Bondarev is washed, unfortunately.
I hate to break it to you guys, but he is a bit washed.
He- in during qualifying- he was the worst Prema.
Like, not a single one of his teammates was behind him.
What? Your teammates are all rookies and David Cosma.
What do you mean you are qualifying worse than all of them?
I don't understand it. I don't understand.
I don't understand if he's just washed, if he was just never good, if there's something in the car that he's not adjusting well to.
Because he wasn't great in Italian F4 last season either, but he was better than this.
So I don't know. I don't know what's happening with Bondarev.
David Cosma ended up on pole for race 1.
And I remember Vallelunga last season, where he also ended up on pole.
He was on pole for two races that weekend last year.
And he lost pole immediately.
And he did basically the same thing here as well.
He went from pole to P8 in the end, but at least he ended up in the points after losing pole.
Because last season he did not end up in the points after losing pole.
I don't want to talk anymore about R-ace, just because it was a horrific weekend.
And I've already talked enough about Andy.
But Tamas (Gender) scored points this weekend, which is very nice.
And he qualified for race 4, which is also very nice.
So we take the positives.
With F1 Academy happening this weekend, the only girls that we had on the field were Emily Cotty and Ginevra Panzeri.
And they both did not have a great time.
Panzeri qualified in the combined qualifying.
She was 42nd in a grid of 43 drivers.
But, just barely qualifying for race 4.
Which is better than a couple other drivers-cough, cough Andy Consani, and Niccolò Maccagnani, and Christian Costoya.
So basically this means that Panzeri is better than all three of them.
Trust me.
R-ace kind of just was struggling this weekend again.
Emily was talking about how she was having issues on the straights, like on her Instagram post.
So just not a great weekend.
In terms of championship standings, Alp Aksoy leads the championship.
Sammalisto 2nd, Cosma 3rd, Robinson 4th, and we still have a Maffi racing in the top 5 of the championship.
I don't understand.
What happened? How did this happen?
And you have those in the top 5.
And then the drivers that we expected to do well are Bondarev in P9, Craigie in P16, Kansani in P18, and Costoya in P34.
This Italian F4 is not a real championship.
Again, we went into the championship thinking, oh yeah, Consani and Bondarev are going to fight for the actual title, and Craigie and Costoya are going to fight for the rookie championship.
That's not happening.
I think we'll be lucky if Consani and Craigie end up in the top 10 of the championship by the end of the year.
I am not hopeful. I thought the 7th and 9th for Powell and Olivieri last season was bad, but at least they never had a DNQ for a Race 4.
In terms of the rookie standings, obviously Aksoy is leading.
In every single race that he has participated in, he's taken the rookie win.
So I don't think anyone's beating him to that.
But yeah, I'm done crashing out over Italian F4.
That was the entire section, just me crashing out because no one else cares about Italian F4.
But moving on to our last series, which is also another F4 series, we have British F4.
So last week we were at Snetterton, and Dries was having a bit of an off week.
He still got two podiums, but he was topping the testing, but then also qualified P7 and retains the championship lead, although we will talk about that a little later.
Getting two podiums is considered an off week for him, it's kind of crazy.
And then Lewis Wherrell also had two wins, so I will explain more about that later as well.
And Belofsky made up nine cases in Race 2 and just needs to sort his quali out.
And then this week we were at Silverstone.
So Dries does no longer lead the championship because he got six penalty points, and after that they start deducting championship points.
So yeah, Lewis is now leading the championship.
I can't believe it.
I also cannot believe it.
I didn't expect him to get that many penalty points so quickly.
And even without the penalty points, Wherrell would still lead the championship because of Race 3, was it?
But either way, this is what I mean about how we're not allowed to talk positively about drivers on this podcast.
Because we were just busy glazing DVL for several episodes, and then suddenly he's no longer leading the championship and he's low-key washed.
What is going on?
We just can't talk positively about anyone.
British F4 was supposed to be the championship where I can just relax and watch my favorite driver in the championship just dominate the entire thing.
But clearly that's not the case.
So like Thia said, DVL has lost a couple points due to getting penalty points.
And there's several other drivers in the field who have also lost points because of that.
And we have a driver who is currently last place in the championship who is on minus 12 points, and that is Haarni Sadiq.
And that is really sad.
A couple other drivers also lost a couple points, but no one really that I feel like I need to talk about.
I mean, we had Hewetson lose a couple points, Jungling lost a couple points.
In terms of drivers who are not on negative points, I am really, really embarrassed for Alfie Slater.
I don't know what is going on with Rodin.
I think Rodin's been struggling a bit recently, and we've seen that with DVL.
But to be where is he in the championship, he is currently 29th in the championship, with only two other full-time drivers behind him.
Being Roman Felber and Haarni Sadiq.
And that is embarrassing, unfortunately.
And I hate to be mean, but I feel like this is a bit warranted.
Because what are you doing?
He has scored a total of five points in the championship, and they're all from overtaking during reverse grid races.
He has not scored a single point from actually being in a points scoring position.
And I don't know, man.
We had a couple girls from F1 Academy here this weekend as well.
We had Alba, we had Ella, we had Emma.
But none of them really had any results to write home about, unfortunately.
There were a lot of red flags.
We had two races that were red flagged and then restarted.
And I'm actually really happy that after the red flag, they restarted with all the time that they were supposed to run the race.
I don't have the words to describe it.
The 20 minute race, for example, even if they've already done one or two laps and then red flagged it,
when they restarted after the red flag, they restarted the 20 minute countdown, which I'm happy about that.
It gives them more time to race.
But yeah, ended up in an incident where her entire car was covered in dust and sand.
And I don't even know what happened, but her car was like...
It wasn't even that her car was destroyed, it was just covered in dust.
Ella had a DNF at some point and Alba, again, nothing really to write home about.
Chiara ended up on reverse grid pole this weekend, which was very nice.
And unfortunately on both starts-because the reverse grid race was one of the races that got red flagged and restarted-
unfortunately on both starts she lost pole position immediately.
But she ended up on the podium still, so that's always really nice to see.
I think it's been a pretty good weekend for women and motorsports in general, with CHiara on the podium and Abbi winning a race in GB3.
We'll talk a little bit about that in a second, but I just want to finish off with British F4.
George Proudford-Nalder stalled from pole in race 1, which was really unfortunate.
It's always really sad when someone stalls from like the front row.
But he ended up winning race 3, and it was kind of a redemption for him.
One of the races had some really, really close finishes, and I don't remember which one.
And that's the problem with having 3 races in one weekend, is that you don't remember what happened in which race.
But one of the races had a really close finish for the podium.
But then afterwards, both DVL and Ethan Jeff-Hall ended up being penalized from the podium anyways,
which promoted Adam Al-Azhari and Jarrett Clark to the podium instead of them.
DVL was for causing a collision with, I don't remember who, was it Joseph Smith? It might have been Joseph Smith.
And then Ethan Jeff Hall was for an overtaking infringement, which I don't know what that means.
Maybe he overtook someone off track or something. I don't know.
But yeah, I think that's it for British F4.
So in terms of GB3, their race 1 was cancelled because of the weather and everything.
So instead they used the grid from their actual qualifying session for race 2 and cancelled the reverse grid.
So Abbi kept her pole position and also went on to win from pole in race 1.
It was really nice to see Abbi win from pole in a non-reverse grid race.
Because we've seen girls get podiums in reverse grid races, but this was purely on merit.
She qualified on pole, she led every single lap, and she won from pole.
And it was really, really nice to see. And I'm very happy for her.
I don't think we have much else to say about GB3.
I did watch all the races, but they were kind of uneventful, unfortunately.
So yeah, not much to say.
So for championship standings, Nikita Bedrin still leads the championship on 140 points ahead of Maxim Rehm, who is on 113.
Nakamura is currently third, but I think there's a couple of rounds that'll clash with F3 that he won't be able to compete in.
So unfortunately he probably won't keep the P3 until the end of the season, but still some pretty good showings from him.
Abbi is sixth in the championship right now, after her win in race 1.
And yeah, GB3 is not a very big championship. We've had 23 drivers.
So there's not much else to say, I think.
So that's it for today's episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast.
I hope you guys enjoyed listening.
Make sure to follow us on all our socials, Twitter, Instagram, and TikTok, at Grand Prixquel.
And let us know if you have any comments or anything you want to say about anything we discussed today.
On our next episode, we are going to be doing another review of the upcoming Feeder Series weekend, which has way too many series for me to name.
So make sure to tune in for that next week.
Thank you for listening.